Jordan Peterson has returned to the public eye
after a very long hiatus due to, as far as I
understand it, being
in a detox clinic in
Russia in order to get off of benzodiazepine,
the benzodiazepines that he became addicted to,
including being in a medically induced coma
for some period of time, then Pieterson going
from Russia to Serbia for further treatment,
eventually getting covid-19. But now he's back
and he's getting back to the interview circuit and
he's already saying really dangerous things. Now,
I'm going to talk about one of the things he
said during an interview with Bret Weinstein.
And I know I'm stepping into a minefield here.
The tricky thing about talking about the things
Jordan Peterson says is that no matter what
his most devoted followers will say, David,
you're misquoting him. You're misunderstanding
him. So even if it appears as though Jordan
Peterson said something that was wrong or wacky
or dangerous, you were the one who doesn't get it.
David, you are straw manning him. But what Jordan
Peterson said is quite dangerous. And I think it's
important to talk about it. But I will
admit that in
this clip we're going to look at Peterson uses
sort of interchangeable and sometimes vague
terminology. So first, we have to figure out what
it is that he is saying. But the general message
from Peterson here is medicine may be responsible
for killing more people than the number of people
that medicine saves. Again, that's what
I'm hearing. Let's listen to the clip then.
I suspect if you did the statistics properly, I
suspect that the medicine independent of public
health kills more people than it saves. I
suspect if you if you factor in phenomena
like the development of superbugs in hospitals,
for example, that overall the net consequence
of hospitals is negative. Now, that's just a
guess. But it's and and it could easily be wrong,
but it also could not be wrong. And that is a
good example. Or that's where my thinking about
what we don't know has taken me with regards
to the critique of what we do. The fact that
it's even plausible is a stunning low, you know,
medical error is the third leading cause of death,
you know, and that doesn't take into account.
The generation of superbugs, for example,
so there is a lot there, but a key quote here for
what we're dealing with is Jordan Peterson saying,
I suspect that medicine, independent of public
health, kills more people than it saves. That's
the main point. And this includes, as he says,
the fact that in hospitals, sometimes people
get infections and medical error and that if you
include all of that, he believes it's possible
that medicine actually kills more people than it
saves. Now, unfortunately, this is not plausible.
This is a completely absurd idea. And in
particular, when we have nearly half the country
doubting the seriousness of covid because of
the nonsense spread by the right for a year
and a huge contingent of covid. And given that
we have to contend with, this is a particularly
dangerous time to be making completely wild,
implausible claims about medicine. Let's take it
piece by piece. First of all, medicine killing
more people than it saves is ridiculous. Now,
he says, aside from public health. So I'll exclude
vaccination from this because he's kind of saying
we're putting aside public
health. He's not saying that,
you know, if you include public health
initiatives like clean water vaccination,
he's saying we're not including that in his
calculation. Think about the sheer number of
people like think about yourself from the time you
were a little kid, ear infection, sinus infection,
things that before antibiotics would kill many
people. Now they don't, thanks to being able
to go to
a doctor, be diagnosed and get antibiotics,
dentistry, the number of people that used to die
because of problems that start with the teeth,
including how teeth problems create malnutrition
where you can't eat, never mind infections in
the mouth, modern dentistry, including fixing
cavities. How many people have been saved by that?
How many people are saved by heart
bypasses in the United States each year?
Who would otherwise die? 500000 heart bypasses in
the United States every single year. Very few have
medical error related deaths associated with them.
Just to pick I mean, we could go through all day
10000 cases of testicular cancer each year, which
medicine treats with a 95 percent success rate.
That's hospitals, that's medicine saving
people. And he actually says in the clip,
you know, I really don't have any idea about this,
but he has such a cult of devoted followers that
now they will take this and they will run
with it. Peterson also talked about medical
error as
the third leading cause of death.
Medical error is a problem, without a doubt, but
comparing it to all the people saved by medicine.
And it should also be mentioned that medical error
has been dramatically overstated. And when good
studies look at it, medical error is not
nearly as bad as some like to claim. Now
there is malpractise malpractise. There is medical
error, of course, but a Yale School of Medicine
study found the real number of truly preventable
deaths in the US in inpatients is about 22000.
You sometimes hear numbers like 40000 to 100000.
Sometimes you hear two hundred and fifty thousand.
That's the number that is sometimes used to say
it's the third leading cause of death. This study
suggests that the number of otherwise healthy
people who died just because of medical error
could be as low as seventy one hundred and that
the rest of the preventable medical error deaths
are in people with a life expectancy of three
months, very sick people. Now, that doesn't make
their deaths any less tragic. It doesn't mean
we don't deal with malpractise and hold people
accountable. But the point is, we're talking about
people who in a
perfect world have three months to live whose care
may have been mismanaged in a way that could have
robbed them of
time.
It's no less tragic, I get it. But the idea of an
epidemic of otherwise healthy people just dying
from medical error, it's quite rare in the United
States, the leading causes of death in the United
States are mostly particular types of disease,
including cancer or others accidents, including
car accidents. OK, this type of stuff from Jordan
Peterson will make some people more hesitant
to get care to get vaccines. And in the end,
Peterson again admits he actually has no idea,
but
he believes
it's plausible. It's really not plausible based on
anything I was able to find about it. So the big
news is that Jordan Peterson is back. Everybody,
for better or worse, make of it what you will.
Friday, March 26th, one day membership special.
We're blowing out memberships. It's a vaccination
related membership special if you would like to
get a membership at an ungodly discounted rate.
Get on my mailing list at David Pakman Dotcom
Friday morning, you'll get an email telling you
exactly how to avail yourselves of this immorally
cheap membership discount that we're offering.